COLT MCANLIS: In this video
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I help some barking
entrepreneurs improve
their network performance.
Will this dog have its day?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Dobermanifesto is a video
microblogging network
exclusively for pets.
Animal-based videos can
be uploaded worldwide
and sent anywhere to be
viewed and experienced.
Their team reached out to me
with a very common problem.
While transferring data to
and from their GCE backends,
their observed bandwidth
was not as high
as they were hoping given their
recent boom in puppularity.
(CHUCKLING) It's a-- the dog's--
ahem.
To establish a baseline
for performance,
I set up two GC instances
in the same zone
and ran iPerf between
them about 100 times.
What's really odd
about this graph
is that it's not getting
the same performance
as the Dobermanifesto group.
In fact, these
numbers are worse.
Obviously I was doing
something wrong with my tests
and asked for a deeper
set of reproduction steps
from their company.
While most of the items were
the same, one thing stood out.
The machine they were testing
on had a higher core count.
They were using 1CPU VMs, while
I was testing on F1 micros.
I updated my test to use
their config and behold
got almost the same
numbers as they did.
This is when I had a
massive facepalm moment.
The documentation
for Compute Engine
states that outbound
traffic from an instance
is throttled to about 2
gigabits per second per core
that the instance
has, which means
that the more virtual CPUs
in your instance, the more
networking throughput
you will get.
In order to figure out what
this looks like in practice,
I set up a bunch of
different core sized groups
in the same zone and ran iPerf
between them a bunch of times.
From the graph,
you can clearly see
that as the core count goes
up, so does the average and max
throughput.
The fix for the
Dobermanifesto group
was pretty straightforward.
Their team took a look
at the pricing list,
the network graphs that
I had generated for them,
and some profiling
on their CPU usage
and decided to go with an
N1 standard 4 machine, which
gave them almost a 4x
increase in the average
throughput but cheaper than
the N1 standard 8 machines.
Boom-- instance performance.
Now, if you'd like to know more
about the Dobermanifesto group,
check out the full article
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud YouTube
channel for more great Cloud
Performance Atlas contents.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]